our life scene was Brandon walk up to
him with a gun pointed at his face and
Michael did this that's the last thing I
seen when I ran new information now
coming to light in the deadly University
of New Mexico shootout as officials say
New Mexico State University power
forward Michael Peake was lured onto
campus so Brandon said though I want to
get back at that dude right pretty much
so what was the plan
nobody was supposed to die nobody was
even supposed to be shot New Mexico
officials released hours worth of body
camera video and interviews from after
the shooting while the University of New
Mexico released security footage of the
shooting itself it happened on November
19th when Peak and the New Mexico State
University basketball team were in
Albuquerque for a basketball game Peak
met up with a 17 year old University of
New Mexico student UNM security video
shows at least three people run up to
Peak and the girl including UNM student
Brandon Travis you can see Travis push
Peak before someone else hits him with a
bat after that Peak and Travis both
exchange gunfire and are both shot
Travis was pronounced dead on the scene
while video shows Peak limping out of
frame he was later Taken to a hospital
with non-life-threatening injuries so
basically he had
um a Tinder date right that
uh over here at UNM and
there was
um
three guys who came up
and there was an incident that took
place at that point
in which Firearms were brandished
bats
um Michael also brandished a weapon
shots were exchanged
um so now we have Michael who was struck
by gunfire at the hospital and we have a
UNM student who was deceased body camera
footage shows investigators speaking
with New Mexico State University head
coach Greg heyer about the shooting I'm
just shaking I'm just sick to my stomach
I'm just so this is so
terrible and disappointing
we don't know if this was some kind of
like rivalry or setup or we don't know
what it is right at this point and
being you know like
was he in self-defense
I can't speak with any of that um
investigators now say Peak was lured to
campus by that 17 year old girl
following a fight at a UNM and NMSU
football game the month before so Mike
Michael was one of the boys he got into
I don't know exactly which boys he
fought like I because I really I was
like dead okay I don't know which boys
they jumped okay but they jumped I know
B was one of them they actually did beat
the beat and B is who B is the one
okay the girl tells investigators she
kept in contact with Peak after the
football game via Instagram when Travis
and other friends found out they hatched
a plan so Brandon said though I want to
get back at that dude right pretty much
so what was the plan
nobody was supposed to die nobody was
even supposed to be shot the problem was
that they just wanted to jump in just to
get the point
investigators identified the men who
attacked Peak as Travis Jonathan Smith
and Elijah Upshaw while speaking with
investigators Upshaw described the
Fallout from the fight at that football
game
I hope my friend fight and I like messed
up my hand pretty bad right here I got
some stitches I got my nose broke
yes sir okay
so do you know who those guys were like
no sir the fight you're involved in the
fight
it's brand pretty
because he's still pretty upset about it
um we we were all pretty like upset
about it the 17 year old girl and
Jonathan Smith have both been charged
with multiple felonies Upshaw has not
been charged
student
shot
people say New Mexico State basketball
player shot a student
that's not going to go over well in
front of 15 000 people
after the shooting surveillance video
catch cat peak near a yellow Camaro
investigators later determined three of
his NMSU teammates were inside the
vehicle at the time and took peek's cell
phone and weapon hours later
investigators retrieved the gun from
NMSU assistant coach Dominique Taylor
you haven't touched it at all just to
open it and take a picture of you and
when they told me where I was at just
foreign
body camera video also shows Peak inside
his hospital room hours after the
shooting he can be heard asking about
the weapon
with the weapons
it might take a while but eventually you
should get your weapon back
it might take a minute though Master
that's my only weapon yeah
yeah no
on December 5th NMSU announced Peak is
suspended from the basketball team
indefinitely he has not been charged
with any crimes the three teammates he
met up with after the shooting were
suspended for one game for the latest
developments in this case and all things
True Crime stay with long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie